see Jeremy Corbyn is the most
Euroskeptic leader of the Labour Party
for 30 years there's no small irony that
the greatest hope of remaineth is now a
man who for years rallied against the
european union corbin represents an old
left-wing school of labour opinion who
see the EU as a capitalist club this
strand was once so dominant that Labour
opposed Britain's accession to the
European Economic Community and Corbin
himself was a vociferous critic for much
of his career I am NOT a lover of the
European Union now the party is
overwhelmingly Pro Europe but is divided
on what to do mix Labour's policy
adopted as their most recent competence
has been to seek the general election
first and then consider all options
including a so-called people's vote now
a confidence vote has been forged last
those who want the people's vote in the
party say it's time for the leadership
to move on Jeremy has always said that
he stands by conference decisions and I
have no doubt that when we've got
through to no he won't do so we're
giving him that little bit of a push to
make sure that he acts swiftly but
there's no agreement on this within
labour ranks there are schools of Labour
MPs from leave constituencies who
wouldn't support the party embracing a
new referendum for me personally I don't
think it's the tactic there is a
sensible one and I think there is a lot
of resentment potentially in the country
and I know a lot of people feel
passionately about remaining in the
European one the opportunity of a second
referendum but you know my preference is
to negotiate an orderly withdrawal from
the European Union and Bhagwati has
reigned up to now but next week Labour
MPs will attempt to bring forward a
motion on a people's vote and the
leadership will have to decide how its
whipped if it isn't whipped in its
favour
his opponents will claim party policy is
being ignored I personally think it
would be a monumental mistake for Jeremy
Corbyn and the Labour Party to
essentially breach the trust of all of
those labour supporters and failed to
fulfil what most people think was
promised I'm told by a source close to
the Labour leadership that the party
will attempt to bring forward
all motion of confidence once the Prime
Minister's plans are known and in
particular if it looks as if she's
heading towards a No Deal then they
think they hope that a handful of Tory
remainders might peel away and bring the
Labour Party towards the precipice of
power and they also tell me that the
Labour leader himself is very unlikely
to back a second referendum in almost
any circumstances thinking that it would
tear the Labour Party apart our country
belongs to all of us
Labour's latest party political
broadcast released tonight focus is not
on brexit but austerity and domestic
issues those are the things about which
the man himself would prefer to focus in
truth on Europe he is largely
indifferent but brexit remains his best
hope of achieving power it is also a
perilous one Lewis Caroll's can use in
Westminster